As I suggested in the question video, we
can use the distributive property to solve
this problem. The difference between this
and problems we've done before is that
the factor outside of the second
parentheses, that we want to multiply
everything in here by, is itself a
polynomial. However, that doesn't change
how we use the distributive property.
We're still going to take this entire
quantity and multiply it by each of the
terms in the second parentheses. So the
first thing we're going to have is
x+2 times x, and then we'll add to that
x+2 times 3.
Great, so this looks a little bit more
manageable, or like each piece will be. At
this point, we're going to use a trick
that we've talked about before. We're
going to use the commutative property of
multiplication. You might wonder, where
will we use that here, but notice that if
we rearrange the order of these two terms.
So instead we'll write x times x+2, and you may
be wondering why is that useful, but as
you can see, if we rearrange the factors
within each term like this, then we have
what looks like just a standard
distributive property problem, like you've
done so many times before. Great. We know
how to handle that, and we can simplify
within each term, rearrange, and combine
like terms. So our answer is x^2+5x+6.